Britt, Forest,
congratulations.
The strength of
your tactical blades
has landed you in the
third and final round
of this competition, which
means that you're both four
short foraging days shy of
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for $10,000.
All you need to do now
is make one of these.
A Halligan bar.
It is an iconic rescue tool.
And here to tell you more about
it is Captain Brian Olith.
The Halligan bar to
the modern fire service
is the multipurpose tool.
It is probably the most
important tool that's
carried on a fire truck
besides water and hose
and the firefighters themselves.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, brother.
Right on.
[music playing]
Today I'm going to start
forging the Halligan.
I'm going to start at the fork
end and just work my way back.
My plan for construction on
this Halligan is forge-weld,
Damascus billet.
Not only is that
going to add strength,
but it will lend a considerable
amount of aesthetic value
to this.
Is this enough steel?
Yeah.
The pressure of being
a retired fireman
and being tasked with making
the very first Halligan
on "Forged in Fire,"
that situation
is not lost on me by any means.
If I think about it too
much, I could probably put
a lot of pressure on myself.
But what I have control
over is my design
and I'm going to do it
the best that I can.
This day is over.
Beginning of day two.
Let's get that steel hot
beat the hell out of it.
What we're going to do
today is we're going
to work on forming the adze.
We're going to stretch
out the handle.
Right now we're just getting
that handle stretched
out to give us our length.
For firefighters,
you're going to want
something with some
heft to it to grip it.
So I'm just coming in here
and I'm squashing my corners
to give it an octagonal shape.
It's really looking
like it's supposed to.
I'm going to do some
grinding and cleanup
and make sure I don't
have any coal [inaudible]..
I got a lot done today.
I'm down to forging
out the forks
and a little bit
of straightening
and then on to heat treat.
Really feeling good about it.
Woo hoo!
Life is good!
Life is good.
Day three, I'm ready
to get this thing forged
and get it quenched.
Get my forks pretty
well shaped up.
Start forging that pike
out and it's looking good.
So now it's time to drip
the hole for the pike.
There we go.
All right, that's a biggie.
Now all we have to do is
get the adze into place
and we're ready to quench.
I get things up
to heat, go ahead
and put it in the quench tank,
and I've got too little oil.
Oh, that's not good.
So now I've got an
incomplete quench.
The only part that's
really not hard
is the really important part,
like the adze and the pike.
Hang on, re-quench on that.
Everything's riding
on this being right.
If this doesn't
work, I'm screwed.
Much better.
It's actually a
really good quench.
I'm happy.
It's a good thing
I'm retired because I
don't know that I ever want
to see a Halligan again.
Beginning of day
four, today were
going to forge out the forks.
And there you have
it, boys and girls.
Let's heat treat it.
This is hands down the largest
tool I've ever quenched.
So what we're going
to end up doing
is we're going to heat
treat the front half,
flip it around, heat
treat the second half.
Let's quench this beast.
She's straight, I see no cracks.
Let's quench the other half.
3, 2, 1.
We have a successful quench.
So, what we're going to
do is simulate a breach.
[music playing]
I'd say it works.
Bladesmiths, welcome to the
car crash extraction test.
To test your Halligan bars, I'm
going to take your Halligan bar
and try to rescue this dummy
inside this crashed car.
Now this is all about how well
your Halligan bars perform.
It's time to find out if your
Halligan bars will rescue.
To test your Halligan
bars, I'd like to introduce
firefighters Jim and Carl.
Welcome, gentlemen.
Britt, you're first.
You ready?
Grip it and rip it.
[music playing]
Hit.
Go!
[music playing]
Hit.
Nice
[music playing]
All right.
Britt, let's talk
about your Halligan bar
here based on the
firefighters' feedback.
First stop, the bar.
It's a little bit heavier
but it's manageable.
When it comes to your spike
and your adze over here,
they function quite well
and they got the job done.
Overall sir, it will rescue.
Thank you, sir.
OK.
Forest, your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Well, we didn't get
dressed up for nothing.
Clear.
[music playing]
Hit.
Hit it again.
[music playing]
Hit.
All right.
Forest, let's talk about
your Halligan bar here.
First up, it's a lighter
weight so it's easier to carry.
Now, the adze over here did
not penetrate nicely inside
and the reason for that is you
don't have a flat surface here.
Not having a flat surface here
when you're making impact,
it kind of shears
off to the side.
But it was effective,
it worked, and more
importantly, it will rescue.
Congratulations, gentlemen.
Your Halligan bars have
passed our first test.
So now we've turned up the heat.
This is our flaming tower test.
Now to test your Halligan bars,
Firefighter Steve and Captain
John are going to
take them and break
through this training door.
Once they're through
that door, they'll
go up three flights
of stairs, use
your Halligan tool again
to bust out that window
to assist in the rescue.
Now no one really knows
what's going to happen
in a rescue situation.
So to test that Halligan
tool one more time,
we're going to drop it from
that three story window.
Awesome.
All right.
Britt, are you ready?
Let's break it.
[music playing]
Hit.
FIREFIGHTER: Right on the edge.
The biggest thing
was the forks.
They're a little too thick.
So Britt, first off, your
adze worked very nicely.
But the width of your forks
was an issue since they're
so thick right here.
Kevin had a hard time getting
that into that doorjamb.
When every second
counts, you want
that to pass right through.
But overall, performed
well, took the fall
like a champ, good job.
Thank you, sir.
All right.
Forrest, you're up now.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
Hit.
Good.
[music playing]
This hitting surface could
be a little bit bigger.
Right.
My guys could miss
it a little bit.
So Forest, right off, the
Damascus was a nice touch.
The forks got into that
door really easily,
but this corner should be sort
of a 90 degree with flats.
That axe kind of
slid off a few times
and you really want a good
driving surface on this.
But all in all, it
survived, good job.
Well done.
Thank you.
Britt, Forest, this has been
an extremely tough competition.
For the first time ever,
we asked smiths to go
back to their home
forges and make
something other than a weapon .
And you've both proven
that you're Halligan tools
are "Forged in Fire" tough.
However, only one of you can be
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Britt.
Congratulations, you're the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Forest, unfortunately
your Halligan tool
didn't make the cut.
Well Forest, you brought us
an attractive and functional
rescue tool.
However, it's lack
of a defined corner
with flat striking
surfaces caused
it to be a little less
effective than your competitors.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
It's all right.
Forest, you made a beautiful
Damascus Halligan tool.
But at this time,
you're dismissed
from the training area.
Good job, brother.
- Thank you.
Good job.
Brit and mine
both performed well.
It's just came down to some
very minor design decisions,
and Britt made some better
decisions and I did.
I'm exceptionally proud of the
fact of being able to represent
the fire department.
Sorry I didn't come out on
top, guys, but you know what?
We gave her a hell of a good go.
[music playing]
Britt, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, man.
Thank you, sir Thank you.
I am the "Forged in Fire"
champion and it feels amazing.
I came in here confident that
I had a pretty good shot.
Forest comes from the
fire service side,
I come from the law
enforcement side.
I thought he made
a beautiful tool.
I simply just made a
slightly better tool than he
did and brought the win.
[music playing]